voici la motivation des coureurs des
années 70 une certaine drogue
[Musique]
voici leur motivation aujourd'hui
rien n'a changé à part peut-être
l'équipement car à son arrivée en france
l'atout de ce nouveau sport c'était son
faible coût c'est le sport le moins cher
une paire de tennis un short ou un
survêtement et surtout une envie de se
défouler de courir de se faire plaisir
dans l'effort et le plus souvent dans
les rues au milieu des voitures
un sport pas cher accessible à tous mais
rapidement les équipementiers flairent
le bon filon et certains stylistes était
visionnaire les stylistes de mode se
sont emparés du phénomène jogging comme
d'ailleurs de l'engouement actuel pour
le sport en général et ils ont réalisé
les vêtements qui ne sont plus réservées
aux seules activités sportives mais que
certains portent même à la vie je pense
que dans quelques années on verra
couramment des gens habillés en
survêtement pour travailler on essaie
très confortable bon pressentiment
car le jogging est adoptée dans la vie
de tous les jours tout en continuant de
séduire les sportifs pas insensible à la
mode c'est à qui aura le plus beau
jogging au coton polyamide 250 les
équipementiers profite de ce filon et
innovent bilan dans les années 2000 on
est bien loin de la course à pied bon
marché
la priorité c'est donc l'esthétique et
les gadgets on ne court plus sans
capteur cardiaque sans accéléromètre qui
mesurent la vitesse et la distance
parcourue et bien sûr sans musique
le nombre de coureurs ne cesse
d'augmenter passant de 6 millions en
2000 à 8 millions en 2010 et 12 millions
en 2018
presque tous deviennent accros aux
gadgets aux nouveaux survêtements et
aussi bien sûr au basket dernier cri à
200 euros
100 euros c'est vrai que ça paraît
beaucoup mais il ya une inflation dans
groening qui fait que toutes les marques
bas sa ligne augmente et le prix sorte
de gage de qualité c'est comme dans
comment
luxe et voilà hélas la running est enfin
devenir un objet de luxe
il ya un loin du jogging en polyamide
bon marché
[Musique]